about six or seven months ago not very
long ago um I was meeting with a
therapist and she asked me to make a
fist and put it in my chest and say the
words I love this
guy and dude I couldn't do
it at first it was funny I was like ah
stupid and she goes do it and I was like
no come
on now this is somebody who I have told
things I've never told anyone on planet
Earth ever
and she Saidi going to sit here and wait
and so I put my hand in my chest and I
smiled but it wasn't a happy smile it
was I'm smiling so hard to keep from
sobbing I can't say those words and she
said that's where you're going to start
she said it's cheesy as this sounds
you're going to look in the mirror and
start practicing saying the words I love
this guy